[Música]
[Aplausos]
olá bonita todos obrigada por ainda
estarem aqui a posso garantir vos que
vai valer a pena ou menos província
final que eu vou mostrar o meu nome será
antônio tem 38 anos e um desejo ardente
chegar aos 90 e ver o que o futuro me
espera
hoje que gostava de vos falar de super
heróis da idade como um poder e também
do futuro vem do passado
falar de passado eu quando era pequeno
adorava em dos quadrinhos o mundo
fantástico e os super heróis
passava horas e horas no quarto dos meus
primos que tenham pilhas de livros ler
as histórias de todos estes personagens
são pessoas fantásticas com poderes
sobre humanos e que usam esses poderes
para transformar o salvar o mundo a
melhorar o mundo
há exatamente está nas nossas cabeças
mais mas pra quem levou uns quadradinhos
percebo que ganhar não é bem assim
porque super heróis na verdade são seres
estranhos desenquadradas ea margem que
tem umas certas características para os
próprios chamam de edições a vocês podem
trazer um ponto de interrogação na nossa
cabeça mas eu sou exatamente explicar
como é que todos conhecem o que não é o
oportuno ter uma pessoa como nós mas
quando se irrita e perde a razão fica
verde gigantes e tem uma força sobre
humana
no início quando eu não consegue lidar
com essa sua característica e ao local
às situações certas criam causa a sua
volta é por isso que eu não tenha minc é
uma opção muito solitária o tacho mané
que também é um outro personagem que
entenda o seu corpo é exatamente a mesma
coisa
no início quando eu não consegui
controlar esta característica é o caos
imaginem por exemplo está acontecendo na
altura errada com
jantar domingo em família quer que
aconteça a toalha da mãe que acontece as
cortinas da sala a mas os super heróis
depois de terem este momento em que
estão perdidos nas suas maldições não é
que estão a tentar encontrar sem
conhecer os seres humanos enquanto o
cliente ao chão e que podem vir a fazer
ao ponto de viragem que começam a ver
essas maldições como simplesmente querer
críticas e alocá los às instituições
certas e aí transforma em super heróis e
nós os comuns dos mortais
admiramos e achamos que o chão o máximo
a que a eu vamos falar agora na idade
como um poder a melhor na idade como um
superpoder nós temos numa numa altura em
que a sociedade nos perto para sermos
mais eficientes mais saudáveis mais
proativos mais empreendedores e unix os
jovens bonitos tudo que vocês possam
imaginar
e muitas vezes nos sentimos precisamente
o contrário não é que faz que é tão alta
que nós nunca vamos ficar lá mais
precisamente os mais velhos sentem isso
todos os dias nós aí eu já foram o
futuro
antigamente não é agora está em 60 70 80
90 e 100 anos a e são constantemente
lembrados de todas estas características
que perderam assertividade proatividade
rapidez e ficaram com outras como a
lentidão a arrecadar dificuldade de
fazer certas tarefas das dores e uma
outra série de coisas mas o que acontece
nós achamos na volta a trabalhar em que
está em super poder simplesmente não têm
noção superpoderes acham que são
maldições e não estão algo caro as
coisas certas
vou te dar um exemplo vivemos numa
altura em que toda a gente diz tempo e
dinheiro tempo e dinheiro não tem tempo
não tem tempo a perder tempo é precioso
e nem a quem é que tem todo o tempo do
mundo
quem é que tem todo o dinheiro em
potência do mundo
os mais velhos prince com uma das nossas
frase eu gostaria fazer as coisas um
bocadinho
quem melhor do que eu sou pra fazer uma
coisa da qual não tem pressa tem todo o
tempo do mundo que também podem fazê la
e muito bem com mais ninguém e eles
também sabem que precisam e não há quem
não é preciso que os jovens muitas vezes
ela numa série de coisas
a idade é super valorizada e o que nós
queremos mesmo mostrar ué esad é uma
característica que deve ser desejável e
positiva e que pode nos falarmos um
futuro melhor ou seja em vez de olharmos
para trás e para as coisas que podemos
nós temos é que olhar pra frente e
promotor possibilidades que se permite
por exemplo se você imaginar em que a
idade média da reforma são 63 anos e
depois a esperança de vida é uma série
mais antes quando fazem as contas
isso dá um gap de 14 e 20 anos após a
reforma a um estudo geológico da câmara
municipal de lisboa que inquiriu os
idosos sobre o que querem vencer e 25
por cento disse que era o princípio do
fim para pensar o quê que passar 20 anos
achar que é o princípio do fim
não vou trabalhar numa jornada que é o
princípio do fim
é o princípio do início do futuro que é
brilhantes nós temos pessoas que vão dos
60 aos 90 anos e consegue esquecer a sua
idade
eu acho que o design tem um papel muito
importante que mostrar às gerações mais
novas que ainda é o valor mas acima de
tudo mostrar aos próprios e os seus
padres que esta idade é um poder e nós
fizemos isso de uma maneira muito
simples nós temos um espaço criativo que
é um é uma incubadora que podem ser uma
incubadora criativa para pessoas com
mais de 60 anos que também é muito
importante que a criatividade é sempre
colocada às gerações mais novas
os espaços criativos não são
freqüentados por pessoas com mais de 60
anos
só vou trabalhar e professores com mais
de 100 tanques estão a pensar juntar se
a nós e tem menos idade
tenho muita pena vou pra casa e sentarem
nos faz esperar uns anos depois vêm ter
connosco têm mesmo que tenha rugas não
há cá queremos antiga tem mesmo de ruas
posicionar a nós
nós fizemos produtos manufaturados a mão
portanto esta questão do tempo como um
poder a e da mestria e da secretaria
como poder e para além disso fizemos
também um workshop e pensando nos
workshops nós garantimos no mínimo 50
anos de experiência que é uma outra
coisa que nós adoramos porque quer dizer
só soprar e muitas velas no bolo do
aniversário é que podem ter 50 anos de
presidente é uma piscadela de olho ao
mundo do trabalho
há um mês e isso que é importante que dá
visão dar lhes um palco e mostrar que o
chão unix e que são imprescindíveis e
que as comunidades precisam deus coisa
que nós fazemos também em os produtos
que nós produzimos todas as peças toda a
nossa comunicação a imagem tudo à mãe do
verão passado mas é uma coisa muito
atual ou seja nós temos um grande
cuidado de ver os novos consumidores as
novas tendências nos novos tipos de
coisas que fazem o que quis o que é que
isto cria isto cria uma ponte entre as
duas gerações a gerações que às vezes
não falam a mesma linguagem época está
no passado e outro apresentou até no
futuro através da criatividade
i e da arte do design todas estas coisas
são construídas e feitas
cria-se uma linguagem comum que é a
linguagem de beleza na ilha linguagem do
storytelling
e aí já não há essa ideia haiti é novo e
eu sou velho
simplesmente as pessoas são pessoas
enquanto designer pensava será que é
possível criar um projeto onde as
pessoas são apenas pessoas e não tem
idade
eu acho que é possível vamos contar a
história da dona rosário que
a senhora que o camisola às bolinhas ela
tem 90 anos a partida sempre nos nossos
nós se vênus trabalha conosco produz as
peças
nós fomos convidados para ir logo de
perto daqui a dois meses ea dançar e
tecnológico em são josé nem eu estava me
tirando da pesca vocês nos carros super
contentes
sim não sabe vamos organizar tudo vamos
todos foi uma festa que é o que
normalmente acontece quando somos
convidados para conferências ou vai
mexer com o grupo da voz
na semana seguinte ao vaticano que diz
afinal acho que não vou sair não vai dar
só então o que se passa é que eu tenho
que falar com minha família e eles dizem
que eu tenho 90 anos que haja uma viagem
complicada está já não devia ir para não
se trabalhar é necessário vai mas pra
mim o mais importante foi essa
capacidade que ela teve de sonhar
criei povo de pesca chinês que pensou
que tem 90 anos nosso querido e pra mim
essa é a maior vitória do projeto
a juíza também a uma senhora que mora há
seis meses o nosso projetos a ela quando
era nova era uma mulher de carreira de
família sempre foi vista como uma pessoa
muito inteligente no entanto muito que
trabalhava muito mas é mais simples que
ela era faia e nós começamos no dentro
do projeto a usá lo em alguma das
sessões fotográficas e valorizar a sua
beleza sua sensualidade nos lábios
vermelhos as roupas e pretende começar a
ser vista por toda a gente à sua volta
como bonita que ela disse e afinal
ninguém é normal disse que eu era fire
mas afinal eu até sou bonita porque toda
a gente disse isso e esta perceção que
tem que mudar ou seja quando nós nos
vemos a nós próprios como uma coisa os
outros não acreditaram e agora para
finalizar quero dizer pode o design e
iniciativas como esta colocaram grupo
suas dos 60 aos 80 anos numa máquina do
tempo e fazê-los viajar até o festival
de música do verão foi repassado no bons
sons
sim é possível estimular e agora gostava
de vos mostrar o vídeo
eles poderem ver a neve deve salvar o
[Música]
pai foi um homem da lei
ae
[Música]
semelhante entregou um show solo
não sei explicar esse ano a nossa
família não chega e vai chegar
[Música]
[Aplausos]